loving kind generous those are just some
of the words used to describe daniel
scully
he's the first nevadan to die from the
coronavirus
good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here at 4 30. i'm christian
casares
i'm kirsten joyce orkomana sat down with
daniel scully's family one year later
in a story you will only see on 8 news
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
they say time heals all wounds but for
families who have lost loved ones the
pain is permanent
i miss him i miss him all the time
daniel scully was the first nevadan to
die from kovid19
one year ago at the age of 69. most of
his family lives in chicago
including his sister [ __ ] who describes
him as a beautiful soul
he was just kind he was good to people
and he was kind of a solitary guy but
those that he let in he was he was a
good friend too adding to the anguish
[ __ ] also lost her mother ida to the
coronavirus
just two months after daniel's passing
we spent the last year not just
missing him but missing the family unit
daniel was a lover of baseball and took
[ __ ] to her first cubs game
his cousin robert missing their constant
conversations about america's pastime
something comes up baseball related
i said i want to tell danny oh i can't
you know look up at the sky and go hey
man and guess what you know
because of what they went through those
closest to daniel want everyone to keep
following health guidelines
this is such a violent pandemic and
they've taken so many lives already just
be courteous be considerate
and get vaccinated do it for the good of
those around you and although [ __ ]
still grapples with grief she knows
daniel's impact was immeasurable he left
behind
a lot of people who really cared about
him orcomanna
8 news now